direction Luynes ou le refuge SPA
affiche complet avec 150 chiens et chats
accueillis tous les jours le centre
reçoit de nouvelles demandes d'abandon
impossible d'y répondre car en été les
adoptions sont elles en chute libre et
les bénévoles viennent à manquer pour
faire face à la situation Benjamin Vatel
à la SPA de Luynes toutes les places
sont prises environ 150 chiens et une
cinquantaine de chasse sont prises en
charge ici c'est l'un des plus grands
refuges de France l'inflation le manque
de préparation pour accueillir un animal
ou un déménagement peuvent expliquer les
abandons
raconte ça va
l'été est habituellement la saison il y
a le plus d'abandon mais depuis quelques
temps les animaux abandonnés par leur
maître sont nombreux toute l'année en
2023 les abandons ont même augmenté de
15% en premier trimestre selon la SPA on
pense que il y a eu quand même un effet
à très covid on a eu beaucoup beaucoup
de demandes d'abandon là cet été ça a
été un cauchemar c'est entre 5 et 10
demandes de prise en charge par jour
donc c'est vraiment énorme on est obligé
de faire patienter mettre les gens sur
liste d'attente parce que
malheureusement on peut pas accueillir
tout le monde on a aussi nos sorties de
fourrière les animaux qui arrivent aussi
sortis de maltraitance et oui les
demandes d'abandon c'est ça n'arrête pas
malheureusement on ne fait pas assez
d'adoption pour pouvoir répondre à
toutes les demandes de prise en charge
le refuge de Luynes compte 16 salariés
mais ne pourraient pas fonctionner
entièrement sans l'aide des bénévoles
étudiant ou jeune retraités ils sont une
trentaine à venir régulièrement pour
entretenir sur le site préparez les
repas promener les chiens et nettoyer
les cages pour être bénévole il faut
être disponible s'investir sur la durée
et bien sûr aimer les animaux Myriam et
bénévole depuis un an je me sens
vraiment utile ce panier il y a une
nécessité on voit bien que c'est très
grand il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
travail il y a besoin de bénévoles avec
la fin des vacances d'été la SPA espère
voir augmenter le nombre de demandes
d'adoption pour que la tension dans ses
refuges redescende